oh boy do we have our hands full today
so i'm going to cut to the chase today
we're going to be going over some of my
personal picks for anime where the main
character gets betrayed
then becomes a badass i know i know
you'd expect the list to be chock full
of revenge fantasies now originally i'd
actually thought of making a list of
purely revenge stories but i changed my
mind i don't think that we should limit
the shows to that specific sub genre so
i decided to expand the scope a little
bit more to feature characters who
underwent betrayal only to use that as
motivation
to become stronger as they always said
what doesn't kill you makes you stronger
right but
before we start i'd like to share some
good news we're just a little over 150
000 subscribers before hitting that
sweet 1 million subscription milestone
let's give a round of applause to
everyone i'd like to encourage you to
share the channel to your friends and
subscribe if you haven't done so already
it does help me a lot and together we
can reach that monumental
milestone together now let's get on with
the list why don't we open with probably
this year's most
controversial series redo of healer
starts the list
at number 10.
now being a healer ain't easy you know
in online games and fantasy worlds
one wrong move and your entire party
gets wiped
one missed timing and the entire raid is
lost while healers carry such a heavy
responsibility their skill set also
makes them very high in demand
and unfortunately prone to being taken
advantage of kyaru's bright future as
the world's greatest healer never
materialized instead he ends up on the
path of torture and abuse but
fortunately for him
he has in him the greatest ability of
all time a healing spell so strong that
it allows him to wind back time carrying
the anguish of his past the time for
vengeance has come
and it's going to be one hell of a show
redo of hila takes some of the popular
elements in revenge fiction and takes
the more controversial aspects to the
extreme pushing the limits of what can
be shown on tv with its violence
shock value and its sexual content but
needless to say i'll put in some content
warnings here for those interested in
watching it
now before we continue i'd like to give
a shout out to the sponsors of this
video punishing grey raven ever wanted
some high octane cyberpunk action
thrills on the go plus
my favorite part of any anime themed
game waifus then
look no further than this game that's
ready to take the mobile world by storm
punishing grey raven punishing grey
raven is a mobile rpg that gives you a
taste of the best of both worlds
combining strategic rpg mechanics and
fast-paced hack and slash gameplay
couple that with the sci-fi aesthetic
and soundtrack that looks hella cool and
you've got one of the best games the
world of mobile gaming has to offer what
i love the most about punishing grey
raven is that in addition to the
gameplay and the character design you
also get one of the best written
storylines out there the game takes you
to a post-apocalyptic world where
machines have taken over forcing
humanity in the space colony babylonia a
fight for reclaiming earth is in place
and you're the one in charge of the
mission leading your own group of
soldiers into the fray the game's had
its global launch and i would love it if
you joined the party let's take to the
field and take back earth together
and all you have to do is to check out
the download link in the description box
to get started on your journey
i hope to see you in battle comrade
if i recall there was a saying that goes
something like he who fights monsters
should be careful
lest he turns into one himself well it's
not a perfect analogy i think that
pretty much sums up ari furetha's
premise
specifically for our protagonist
hajime's character arc sent into an
isakai world with the rest of his class
and getting the overlooked transmutation
ability resident geek hajime finds
himself betrayed by his classmates sent
down into the abyss and left alone to
die he barely clings on to life he
struggles to survive and becomes
stronger by fighting ferocious monsters
only to meet the vampire yui together
with her hajime looks to find his way
back home
starting the tale of an ordinary boy's
journey to become the world's
strongest like redo of gila earlier ari
fured that made some noise back in his
days
this time it's mostly for the memes
regarding the cgi however once you look
past the admittedly hilarious graphics
ari fureta ends up a pretty entertaining
piece of popcorn entertainment if you're
up for gloriously overpowered
protagonists with a supporting cast that
makes the squad look like some kind of
edgy corner super then this might be the
show for you
next up is hit light novel adaptation
stigma of the wind
if you weren't around during the late
2000s and saw stigma of the wind i
wouldn't blame you if the show reminded
you of shakugan no shana however passed
a red-haired female lead with flames in
the romance the two shows are actually
quite different
and it all starts with the premise of
the main character stigma of the wind
introduces astute
zuma who's been sent into exile after
losing a fight to his second cousin and
that's a top tier stereotypical asian
family right there jokes aside kazuma's
actually talented at something
nope it's not flame magic which he's
absolutely terrible at but
it's actually wind magic it proves to be
a curse as a series of murders involving
wind magic has gazuma in the crosshairs
of the ganagi family and said second
cousin ayano it's a fight for survival
to clear his name and unravel the
mystery of the murders just like ari
furreta before stigma of the wind
features an overpowered light novel lead
however kazuma is more of the
hiding your true powers type and i'd
have to say that his interactions with
ayano are pretty entertaining the
visuals alone can put the show above
arufuretta but i think that the story
also ends up being quite interesting
we move on to classic literature and
what better title to represent the idea
of a hero getting betrayed only to
become stronger than gankutsuona
the count of monte cristo is probably
the quintessential story about a person
being portrayed and coming back stronger
so it's a no-brainer that an anime based
on such book is on this list gaan gutsuo
generally follows the story of the
source material with some deviations
however what i find the most striking
about this show is its unique
presentation the art's already an eye
catcher and while it may take a while to
get used to
it gives the show its own unique look
and appeal while the adaptation style is
loose i'd say that the actual execution
of the plot is still intriguing enough
to keep me invested in the revenge story
at hand with the count of monte cristo
becoming a legendary title amongst the
revenge stories the world seed it's a
given the gangutsu
will have high expectations i'd say that
the story passes those expectations with
flying colours
and a wood vouch for this series this is
one of the shows that went under the
radar but the series is completely worth
your time
one thing that will always be on a list
like this is shield hero
the way i see it shield hero is the
series that popularized the subgenre to
the mainstream and i'd say that the
anime community couldn't have picked a
better show for it shield hero stars now
for me one of the four heroes summoned
to defend the kingdom against waves of
monsters his promising journey starts
off quite rocky
being framed for crimes and being
shunned by his fellow heroes and
citizens left alone with only his
companion
the demi-human slave raftalia the two
set forth on a journey of redemption in
order to protect the kingdom of melromak
i earlier claimed that shield hero is
one of the best revenge series but i
meant that in terms of putting the sub
genre on the map it's not the best story
by a long shot it's got a lot of little
things that ensured its success
a sympathetic lead a nice fantasy world
an easy to follow plot and lots of cool
and cute character designs i know it's a
bit polarizing but i also really enjoy
the dynamic between now for me and
raftalia
next up is yonah of the dorm
we've seen this story before now haven't
we sheltered princess living a life of
luxury before an internal betrayal turns
that world upside down
sending her life spiraling into a living
hell while that happens
said princess starts to see the kingdom
for what it really is as her horizons
get broadened during the seemingly
impossible quest to regain the throne
it's not the most unique of stories but
if there's one thing that managed to
make that premise work so excellently
it's yona of the dawn it's a great
coming-of-age adventure that showcases
some amazing art and a very captivating
storyline it also helps that the
characters down to the side characters
are well developed yonah herself is a
great protagonist that people root for
and i think that she plays the role of
the naive heroine who gets an eye opener
very well due to its genre and the
nature of the plot and characters i'm
not really surprised that the series
isn't so mainstream
however i do urge you to give this a
shot you won't regret it
the last stop before the top three takes
us to the chaos of the prohibition era
91 days
[Music]
it's pretty refreshing to have such a
western aesthetic in anime for once and
i feel that it's rare for anime to cover
some historical periods in america like
the prohibition era the lawlessness and
the anarchy
of the era is made all the more evident
with the start of the story which sees
angelo's family being murdered by the
mafia now as we all know
tragedy only fuels the fire in the heart
of the survivor and young angelo leaves
the town
and re-christens himself avilio seven
years later he finds himself back in
town with vengeance in sight he quickly
encounters a member of the mafia family
responsible for his family's death and
thus begins the first step to his seven
year plan of finally
exacting revenge overall 91 days is a
gripping thriller about a man's path to
vengeance it's a blood stain path that
will keep you in suspense and you'll
find yourself wanting more and more as
the plot unfolds i really recommend this
show and amongst the others on this list
i think that this is one of the most
underrated shows out there
berserk is one of those series that's
transcended generations
it could be due to its sheer boldness in
depicting violence and the more
unglamorous side of anime combined with
beautiful character writing whatever the
case berzerk's been immortalized in the
anime community for good reason these
days
some people clown berserk for the 2016
adaptation but when you put that one
aside you can see a story that is
legitimately good berserk has carved its
way to immortality due to being such a
gripping story about survival
betrayal and the reality of battle it
has a lot of cathartic moments and
showcases a whole slew of tragedy and
redemption for our characters if you're
looking to get into berserk i'd suggest
watching the 1997 series for me it's one
of the best adaptations of the source
material
and it has 25 episodes worth of content
for you to enjoy the story it's toned
down compared to the manga but it still
gets his point across fairly well i'd
also recommend you watch the third
berserk movie which i think adapted the
eclipse really well
we proceed to second place with fan
favorite finland saga
it's unlikely that you're going to need
an introduction to this epic journey
that chronicles the story of vikings
finland saga it seems has been on
everyone's watch list since it debuted a
few years back i would say
it does deserve it though villain saga
takes us back in time as it chronicles
the journey of torfin a promising youth
he finds his world embroiled in chaos
with the death of his father
the culprit the notorious ascolad they
say that you should keep your enemies
closer so tawfin finds his way into the
squad of the mighty viking leader hoping
to one day exact revenge on the man who
killed his father
in the midst of war and destruction will
he ever get that chance for sweet
revenge finland saga completely deserves
the praise being showered by it it's
suspenseful
thrilling and will always keep you on
the edge with its action scenes it also
helps that the show is amazing in terms
of characterization and development
definitely a recommendation
considered by many to be one of the best
anime not just in modern times but just
all time generally i think that not a
lot would argue attack on titan's
placement on this list the show that
sent
shockwaves to the anime world that can
still be felt today has all the makings
of an animated masterpiece it just
amazes me how it manages to weave so
many character stories
shocking twists and foreshadowing
together to create a series that will be
remembered for years to come
it started out as a show about fighting
monsters that captivated audiences due
to its subversion of the usual anime
tropes but then it became very political
and philosophical
it takes quite the genius to come up
with a mix of those genres and make it
work but the madman is sayama did it you
also get to admire the character work
and the underlying themes of the series
something which i tackle a lot on my
other channel catered to my video essays
the link for that's in the upper corner
love it or hate it attack on titan is an
amazing series that will endure the test
of time and i can go to any length as to
why such an amazing series
action drama a constantly evolving and
immersive plot it's just got everything
and that's why it's my number one series
featuring a main character coming back
stronger after betrayal so which is your
favorite amongst all of these shows make
sure to tell me in the comments section
perhaps you can also introduce me to
some of the shows in the same vein while
you're at it that's it for this list
check out channel memberships or my
patreon if you're up for supporting the
channel monetarily those contributions
will go a long way in helping me make
these videos
even better don't forget to check out
our sponsors game punishing grey raven
the link's in the description
thanks for the time and i hope you
enjoyed the list till next time